we're in the capital of tajikistan just
to the north of
afghanistan where as a result of a swift
pullout
by the us-led coalition the crisis is
deteriorating
day by day the taliban is pretty much in
control of the entire country
apart from the kabul region and this
could easily
spill over the border now
as the russian minister of defense was
meeting his counterparts
from the neighboring countries here in
dushanbe he blamed
the us for the situation that's getting
increasingly dangerous
the hasty withdrawal of u.s and nato
troops creates lots of problems
we're aware of the ongoing robust work
aimed at providing security on the
border which is currently a hotbed for
many risks
threats and challenges if you look at
the map
of afghanistan you will see that it is
surrounded by countries that are
russian allies from two different blocks
one is made
out of post-soviet countries and the
other one is russia's
alliance with china together with some
of the different neighbors now
what moscow wants to do is to reassure
its neighbors that
it is ready to help at any time if the
situation gets
worse moscow has a military base here
in tajikistan near dushanbe that is
ready for action at any time the other
thing that
russia wants to do is to cement its key
role in the region
which doesn't make the us happy as i've
heard when i spoke exclusively
to the head of the russian army here in
dusan bay
the announcement of the u.s withdrawal
is clear to everyone it's taking place
indeed
simultaneously the u.s is holding talks
with all the countries adjacent to
afghanistan
on establishing certain logistical hubs
on their territories
it begs the question what's the point of
pulling out while remaining on the
border
the answer is obvious it's an attempt to
retain its position in the central asian
region
after failing absolutely everything in
afghanistan
when it comes to instability after the
u.s give me at least one example where
the situation has been improved
after a long-running u.s presence now
here's a fact for you when more than 25
years ago sergey shoigu was the head
of russia's emergencies ministry he was
in charge of an entire
operation of rescuing refugees that were
flowing
out of afghanistan beyond the soviet
pull-out
and also when the soviet union collapsed
and the situation in afghanistan was
deteriorating because
of stronger islamist groups
in the country now this is why the local
ministers of defense
and leaders praised sergey shoigu's role
in sorting out the current situation one
of the proposals that came
from the russian ministers of defense
was to intensify the drills between
russia and its allies here and the first
part of these drills
called peace mission will happen
in september and china is also going to
take part
in those